barkley
here we go i just love barkley saying
this by the way love hearing what
barclay
charles barkley to leave the inside the
nba blames cancel culture
we can't even have fun anymore go up a
little bit to read what he says
baseball legend charles boxing decade
long tienes and simon chan and he blames
cancel
an appearance on washington uh radio uh
sports radio station wjfk
106.7 the fan mr barkley slammed as
jackasses the social justice warriors
who launched online attacks and even
criticized as bosses
and co-hosts on tnt it's gotten so out
of right out of hand right now
i couldn't imagine having to watch
myself you can't even have fun nowadays
without these jackasses trying to get
you canceled
and things like that he continues to say
he's 58 years old right and he says
i'm just having fun talking about sports
i'm trying to hang hang on for another
couple years until i'm 60 and then they
can kiss my ass i'm only working until
60.
i already told them that we can't even
have fun anymore we have had fun all
these years
and all of a sudden in the last year and
a half everybody is trying to get
everybody fired it really sucks can you
imagine
barkley talking about this and then
we're going to talk about the scenes yo
man be careful going in that direction
all we ever talk about behind the scenes
is yo man be careful going in that
direction we can't have fun anymore
we've had fun all these years and
all of a sudden the last year now same
thing here so
barkley i i don't know how many emmys
has won i think it's eight
i don't know the number how many emmys
has barkley won can you pull it up
i think he's won eight nine he's won a
bunch of emmys right
here's a guy that's won a bunch of emmys
he's loved admired probably the best guy
to listen to entertaining his hell
he keeps that show together if you think
about it he has one for him
the blue guy he's the glue guy even shaq
says the shaq says the face of this show
is charles barkley shaq he said the face
of the who also together
is charles barkley right to say
something like this how much credence do
you give to what he says right there tom
i give a lot of credence and i'll tell
you why um i
love barkley you and i had the privilege
of um in dallas going to see him speak
one time
yes yep at a um you know a
college function that was there and
what's really interesting
is i think was about six weeks ago
barkley
on camera on stage during the show said
you know what
i'm getting tired of what these
politicians are telling people to
believe
because i think black most black people
most white people
most hispanic people are all good people
they're all good folks and they're
getting tied up into this thing remember
that he gave that little speech
and i thought that was so pure and so
necessary for him to say you know what
the people i see i think everybody of
all colors is basically good and they're
getting revved up by outside forces
do we need have things in america that
need to be addressed yes
do we have things need to be changed yes
do we have historical things that have
kind of followed
us around that we have a chance to get a
new generation thinking differently
yes but right now the majority of people
are good people as we work through all
those things
but they're getting revved up by the
government that wants power and pitted
against each other
and he's talking here these jackasses
are just trying to get you fired
it's a technique of lobbying now to get
someone
fired for having anything other than no
opinion
i think it's terrible what's going on
with charles bro i think he
uh to tom's point i do agree with him
here look
charles barkley is a personality uh even
when he was playing in the nba he had a
larger-than-life personality he went
against the grain he said i'm not a role
model remember that famous commercial
tell your kids not to listen to me who
says that what adult says that
so this guy's been cancelable before
cancel culture was a thing
but he's maintained it for the last 30
plus years i think something that is
resonating i mean what sign what side
politically do you think
charles barkley leans center center what
he's probably center period center okay
well i think he's more center left i
mean he
supported doug jones in alabama he
supports more democrats than he does
republicans sure that's for sure
okay which way do you think bill maher
leans politically as an example center
left center left okay
left so you have there's a theme here
going on here even me for example
charles barkley center left uh
bill maher a little more left but seems
like he's coming center
me a little more left especially
socially fiscally a little more right
coming a little more center and what's
the common theme we're all basically
seeing
what's happening with this wokeness and
this cancel culture and we're like this
is ridiculous
being woke you know a few years ago
actually was a good thing
meaning i'm aware of what the hell's
going on i see what's going on i have an
opinion
i'm not just sleepwalking through life
now woke hezekon
has done a complete 180. and if you're
woke that just means you're part of this
you're canceled your cancer culture aunt
jemima you're done
redskins you're done you did this 20
years ago you're done
cancel fired you're done and that's a
very slippery slope and i think that's
exactly what charles barkley is talking
about here
is that if anything you say or anything
you do
is automatically cancelable and a
cancelable offense
that's not america anymore you know you
know what uh uh
uh eisenhower said in his farewell
speech
when he was uh coming out do you know
what he said do you know do you know
what direction i'm going with this guy
or no what's this thing
okay he said in his speech he says
beware of the military-industrial
complex
okay and what he said about this is the
following he says
if if you use the word communism to try
to cancel
anybody be very careful with that just
because somebody uses the word
communism you don't cancel them this
started off with
them right which was right hey i have
200 and something people kind of like
adam schiff saying i have proof here
that the trump was colluding with russia
i have proof here right and there's been
no proof that he ever brought up
and so this cancel culture thing
is something you have to be very very
careful with
you know lincoln has a quote i'll look
for to read it to you
and he says the same exact thing it is a
like he was talking about prohibition
where people are using prohibition to be
able to arrest anybody
i mean if you're going back and you
think about these laws that we came up
with right you go back and think about
the the mccarthyism was what if you're
communist anybody that's your friend i
can come after them as well and tape
them right very dirty then that goes to
rico what did rico allow you to do
in 1970 and ricochet racketeering but
what rico allowed you to do is
for if he's even hanging out with you i
can record his house without even
getting permission
slippery slope and enrico led to omnibus
and omnibus led to patriot act
it's more control control control
control control right okay
today if you think about
who's doing most of the silencing which
side of the aisle is it today
yeah it's that will definitely be the
left at this the left especially at
universities is that's like the big
knock away number one is universities
yeah number two is social media number
three is
you know i mean i can go on and on you
can't people people don't feel
everybody who said anything about the
virus being
man-made got cancelled until jon stewart
said it on stephen colbert
yeah there's just when he said it on
stephen colbert that video went viral
why does he go viral and stephen colbert
doesn't get cancelled
but everybody else that talked about it
the last 12 months they got cancelled
you know how many videos were being
canceled because just because we had a
person that sits
say what they said so the the the
there's a reason for that
which is what i think a lot of people
are willing to listen to people that are
on their team before they're willing to
listen to someone on the other team
telling them what's right or wrong so if
john stewart who's traditionally
a liberal no one on the right is going
to listen to him as an example
right you're it's a lot of echo chambers
jon stewart i disagree
i think he's what do you mean he's a
liberal senator always listen to john
stewart
you're one of the few no many many
people
the point that i'm getting here is the
macro respectively i think john stewart
is reasonable it's a lot easier yeah i
think he's smarter
if you're i'll just be very clear here
it's a lot easier if you're a democrat
yeah to convince other democrats hey
guys your way of thinking is a little
wrong you need to figure this out
versus a ted cruz trying to convince
democrats to think a certain way versus
a democrat an adam schiff character or a
stephen colbert speaking to republicans
trying to convince them versus
donald trump saying hey guys you got to
change up how you're thinking i think
the point that i'm getting at is that
you're willing to listen to someone
that's on your team before
someone that's not on your team so it
takes someone like a jon stewart
to wake up the the left if you will
as to maybe the virus i agree with that
i think meaning
it takes somebody from your own side to
wake you up yeah it's a call yeah but i
also think the reason why
a lot of people were silenced the last
12 months is not because it's an
opposing idea it just doesn't fit the
narrative
so if you're trying to drive a narrative
narrative narrative narrative narrative
you have to silence
anybody that doesn't fit the narrative
and that's what happened the last 12
months
okay and so and now they're sitting
there saying well you know
yeah you're right it could be man-made
well we don't know who says we can't be
man-made not
so it's a very very slippery slope uh to
go in a direction like that
and uh i i applaud listen i said this
yesterday
i said walking on eggshells
and cancel culture it always eliminates
the most talented
entertaining people barkley is the most
talented entertaining person he steps
away
i agree kevin hart was supposed to host
the damn oscars
he's the most entertaining funniest guy
at the time the guys were getting box
offices he was making records after
records after record
to the point where he tweeted something
the other day i sent him a message he
says much love and i appreciate you
you know it's just congrats on
announcements we're going back and forth
texting each other
there are certain people that you lose
like we want the ricky gervais we want
to build birds we want the chapels we
want the
kevin harts we want the barclays but no
they offended somebody
they offended somebody you got to be
very careful because you can't say that
god forbid
you offend somebody and then nicole
nickelodeon the other day they post a
offended
video on the left nickelodeon posted a
video the other day trying to please the
transgender community you saw the
numbers when the collodion
did you see what happened when
nickelodeon's number after that ad that
went up sure it plummeted
oh it's not even plummeted it's
catastrophic
catastrophic because transgender is not
a democratic thing
democrats some democrats are sitting
behind closers like listen i'm not
i'm not like why are you putting that in
my kid's face
if you support it support it but this is
nickelodeon what are we doing here oh to
try to please a small percent
what percentage of america is
transgender like one percent
it's not even one percent no no it's
probably one percent of one percent
so to try to please the one percent of
one percent
but you throw the other 44 under the bus
and you lose that audience it's not only
it just doesn't make sense it's not even
a good business model
to do that there's there's nothing about
it that makes any sense
did you did you see that video uh of
it was a family yeah asking hey would
you take a picture of us
and they give the camera to uh just a
random guy and it's like a
family of five and he goes okay say
cheese and they
excuse me i'm actually a vegan i don't i
don't do cheese
okay so we won't say cheese all right
everybody
smile well you know i'm actually
depressed right now so i'm not willing
to smile
and and basically every family member
has an excuse
as why they couldn't take the picture
and it just started with seychelles and
this poor guy is like yeah he's like
dude do you want me to take a bathroom
i'm out
so i'm sorry here's your camera back
yeah
yeah i mean it's listen more power to uh
barkley in two years we're gonna lose
him enjoy the guy for two years
well i told him it's fair to say chuck i
know you're a big fan of the the podcast
you have a seat here to my right tom
will have to send this one out
but anytime that charles barkley wants
to come on we'll
have to bring him on i'm a guest here
and i appreciate it but i would love to
sit back and watch sue charles on this
program all right hey so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you